please don't go hey guys as you can tell
it is the holiday season which means it
could be any time of year there are
holidays that happen all throughout the
year constantly what why do we call it
holiday season now just because it's
Christmas Kwanzaa Hanukah etc a lot of
beauty gurus here on YouTube show their
nighttime routines and I'm obsessed with
them it seems silly I guess to watch
what someone does before they go to
sleep
it doesn't seem silly it seems psychotic
and perverted so I do it alright so I
thought I'd show you guys my nighttime
routine because it happens it happens to
me after a long day of work or just like
staring at any wall I like to make
myself a light refreshing meal something
that's just super heavy and kind of
depressing and full of sodium something
that really allows you to look like you
had allergic reaction to Botox the
morning after then I love to wind down
the night with a cup of tea I think this
is just the best way to settle your
brain after staring at one to four walls
I use a really organic recipe no
preservatives Oh puke then I like to get
out of my work clothes an inch something
or comfortable perfect then I like to do
some light aerobic exercise something
that stimulates my body and lets my
brain not have to think about all of
that wall looking finally after that I
followed up with some light yoga just to
calm down my body and my mind
from there it's into the bathroom for
all of my beauty secrets here's a secret
I like to brush my hair at night
sometimes even wash my face and brush my
teeth am i a witch I don't know I'm not
here are some of the products I use on
my face and body before I go to sleep
occasionally I spend upwards of 4 hours
staring at the shower wondering what
could be if I used it then I like to
look into my mirror and give myself some
daily affirmations that keep me going
and when I'm finally done in the
bathroom I tell all the invisible people
around me not to use it because I just
took a huge dump I'm quirky and last but
not least I like to snuggle up with a
great book read it and let it inspire me
I'm finally drift off into sweet hot
dirty dreamland there you go that was my
nighttime routine I hope that you
enjoyed this I hope you felt cleaner and
more inspired by what you saw here today
I don't know
hey guys don't forget if you like this
video to subscribe what a concept and if
you really like this video click like
just so I know because I need validation
that this is okay to present to you also
feel free to leave a comment down below
let me know if you do any of these
things when you get ready for sleep
times at night or during the day I don't
know what your schedules like I live a
candle I really should care about this
video you guys